voici le résultat de l' incendie du 24
décembre un hangar de 400 mètres carrés
entièrement détruit ou quatre
entreprises stocker leur matériel dont
quelque cent cinquante mille livres
d'une petite maison d'édition orléanaise
bas c'est une catastrophe pour une
entreprise d'avoir tout son stock qui
disparaît une semaine plus tard les
témoignages de soutien affluent la
palette de tons livre a brûlé au bout du
fil
l'un des auteurs de cet ouvrage sur de
gaulle il est tout aussi inquiet que
l'éditeur lui même
nous avons un engagement vis-à-vis de
centaines d'auteurs et que nous devons
c'est le travail de l'éditeur de porter
leur message leurs travaux leur leurs
récits et c'est pour ça que nous devons
nous battre pour survivre il faut
d'abord faire un inventaire précis des
pertes
voici à quoi ressemblaient les 72 m² de
livres entassés au fil des éditions
depuis 2012 dans ce local partis en
fumée
l'éditeur indépendant espère une
indemnisation rapide de son assureur
mais a aussi lancé une cagnotte de
soutien en ligne car 2020 pourrait bien
hélas écrire le mot de la fin d'une
histoire entamée il ya 26 ans l'année
2020 des semaines entières ou les
librairies sont fermés les libraires qui
n'ont plus de sous qui ne nous paye plus
les salons du livre
très limité et cette catastrophe
les prochaines semaines seront cruciales
pour les éditions corsair un acteur
modeste mais nécessaire à la richesse de
l'industrie du livre en centre val de
loire